[Musique]
déjà qu ami d'emilie gironde et auprès
de la vie site ou encore hélas tu cieux
peine
john wood
c'est aussi le plus sérieux à jouer il
suffit de vouloir devenir un ami
bon bah ça suffit qu'est ce que tu fais
avec salah reste suit sur le sentier de
la guerre alors bord ouais c'était puise
est oui je filais oui je pourrais
trappistes escargot qui m'énerve quoi
rapide aux semi rapide hausse mais tu
vois là je me suis coincé dans le sinaï
et douala
mais qu'est ce qui t'a fait rapido il
vient tout le temps d'ennuyer il ya me
dit me koubbi
quand je dis des choses il serait mieux
de dire bonjour à tous nos amis ce
serait tout de même plus polis bonjour
bonjour bonjour à tous et nous allons
commencer par la tranche géographique
qui vous concerne bien entendu avec tes
trois éléments toujours les mêmes
créneaux description du pays
1 le drapeau le drapeau et le bonjour
bonjour dans la langue du pays
voilà alors on commence par la carte du
pays bon à regarder bien cette carte
vous vous apercevez immédiatement que
c'est un pays bien entendu pour lequel
la mère a beaucoup d'importance
il est bordé par la mer vers la mer et
entourée par la mer
ici la capitale c'est une base capitale
comment jeudi elle est basse oui enfin
les bans elle est là oui voici le
drapeau du pays à un drapeau dont vous
voyez bien entendu la forme mais pour
ceux qui n'ont pas la couleur je précise
qu' il est bleu blanc blanc avec la
croix blanche sur fond bleu bien et pour
dire bonjour dans ce pays
tu vas nous le dira tout qu'encore on
dit kalimera oui kalimera kalimera vous
allez vers à madame kalimera monsieur
kalimera mademoiselle il s'agit de la
grèce c'est la grèce avec sa capitale
athènes
et puis on n'a pas figuré sur la carte
les milliers d'îles qui appartiennent à
la grèce et qui sont un petit peu autour
si vous voyez la crête par exemple que
j'ai une très grande il ya aussi des
choses à mais j'aime beaucoup la grèce
et j'y suis allé ça j'adore ça la grèce
en ma faveur et trop inquiets tout
seigneur tu connais tu éclaires il joue
très bien sur j'ai levé le gel de
l'hiver
moi mais tu as raison vador jardin moi
je vais retrouver belle belle épouse
moût sujet d'accord si tu vois
l'escargot 1
si tu vois escargots ne lui dit rien
bong encore qui publie ce cas la
victoire on est là on a beau je suis
avec vous on est bien un appel appel
fabrice abri oui abri oui bah une petite
seconde à avant même nom se veut pas
être bousculés comme ça qu'est ce que
c'est que ça m'avait pas vu il était pas
dans le jardin là aux alentours un
roadie non oh non je n'ai pas fait
attention à toute façon je ne veux pas
être mêlée à vos querelles ça je tenais
déjà dit je ne veux pas elle rallonge au
point comme belles belles bougies
monsieur et tout cancon seront soit les
jeunes faisaient ce soit des choses ou
des situations et c'est le problème
consiste à trouver quel est le point qui
les unit le point commun soyez très
attentifs
écoutons tout d'abord tout cas encore
bel et bien fabrice si tu aimes la
difficulté aujourd'hui qui va être servi
ah oui parce que je représente
aujourd'hui un endroit où on peut dire
que le travail est difficile il faut
être fort pour le faire et courageux
mais alors c'est un travail très très
utile s'il n'y avait pas des hommes
capables de passer des journées et des
nuits dans cet endroit que je représente
eh bien quoi moi il faudrait se passer
de beaucoup de choses on aurait des
difficultés pour se chauffer l'hiver
pour avoir star tartine de paix et son
café au lait le matin et à des ya même
des usines qui s'arrêterait à je n'ose
pas penser à tout ce qui est vrai que
j'aime mieux me taire oui tu es toi à
moi de paris moi aussi je suis un
instrument de travail mais je peux te
faire un tableau plus souriant des gens
qui utilisent ce sont des enfants des
dessinateurs des architectes des
comptables moi personnellement ma foi je
n'y tiens pas beaucoup de place
je peux vivre au chant bureau dans une
trousse et même dans les poches d'un
veston attention il faut se méfier de
moi car je suis très fragile on ne doit
pas me brutaliser d'ailleurs c'est bien
simple si on me manie trop durement je
me casse et après on est obligé de me
soigner
je ne vais pas ré
de me tailler fabry on commence à avoir
une petite idée et j'ai un caractère
très pointu enfin c'est très bien pour
se servir de moi si je suis point tu
dirais même que shipit quand je vois je
vois je vois un bon bah moi moi moi je
suis très embarrassée parce que c'est
pas du tout comment expliquer ce que je
suis je suis une chose à laquelle on
donne toutes sortes de qualificatifs à
certains ont dit qu'ils en ont une bonne
à dos tandis que les mauvaises
il ya même quelqu'un qui m'a dit un jour
que la mienne ressembler à du papier
mais attention pas pas du papier
ordinaire à du papier manche et je pense
que c'est moi tu papier mâché même éclat
sur sa pas l'air du tout d'un compliment
à la suite de ça je peux me regarder
dans une glace pour essayer de
comprendre ce qu'il avait voulu me dire
ben non moi je pense qu'ils s'étaient
trompés
tu imagines pourquoi est ce que j'irai
même média a marché du du papier ou soit
pas c'est pas grave
non non c'est pas grave on fera tout de
même du papier mâché le soir avec ce bon
voilà je pense que le point commun dit
pardonnez-moi mais peut-être j'aurais pu
donner ma version
mais non
rapide aux containers fait attention on
se ballade soul i will call me back
contre pas cet état d'esprit mais ça me
fait rire laisse-le parce qu'après va il
va être énorme
c'est pas étranger il ne connaît pas les
moeurs du pays c'est pour ça bon alors
je vais essayer de le rencontrer et de
lui parler oui mais bon là je vois tout
à leur belle belle je voudrais quand
même dire que le poids comme un tu
désuni et c'est lamine sylla oui bah oui
l'ami amis il a trouvé la mire la ligne
de fer ou du charbon pour tout cas
encore la mine de crayon pour bébé et il
ya une bonne ni mauvaise manche et pour
ce poste monsieur mine alors que puyol
l'année comme ça avant de te laisser
parler à tout à l'heure d'abord tu
prépares notre psyché weeds à quoi bon
alors c'est à nous à maintenant
mavericks plus ça va ça va être
c'est à nous oui à nous deux alors qui
va au tableau oui comme d'habitude
j'espère que tu n'as me reposer là oui
quelque chose de gentil le gentil gentil
simple agréable où j'espère que tu n'as
pas oublié ton cailloux non plus je lai
tu l'as à moi j'espère tu n'as pas
oublié ton orthographe non non je l'est
aussi
oui enfin j'espère oui alors on rêve
bien commence par quoi alors basé
d'abord je vais te dire cette amo en
neuf lettres d'abord le mot étant neuf
les prix alors il commence par un a à 1
à à à
alors je fais cette très pour les
lettres qui manquent exactement trois
cinq sept îles par la dernière c'est un
des 1
des bons ou encore tu as quoi dans
l'émoi
oui comme kiffis y est oui alors s'il
vous plaît rapidos laissez nous sommes
enfin je ne veux pas rejeter passibles
s'ils vous gêner alors bon alors alors
est ce que c'est une fleur à non donc ce
n'est pas un c'est pas une fleur est ce
que c'est une plan oui j'ai d'une plante
à trouver est ce que c'est une plante
qu'on trouve couramment francs oui il y
en a beaucoup on la leur à wimby
beaucoup beaucoup surtout en bretagne
doit envoyer d'un peu mais ce que est ce
que ça se mange
oui oh oui oh et puis c'est très très
bon à sa semence voudrais tu me donner
une autre oui mais je vais te donner la
troisième lettre s'il te plaît la
troisième lettre ces teintes et atterrit
ça sonne bien et sa semence avec de la
vinaigrette avec la vinaigrette
oui comment taisez-vous rapidos autre
atout il recommence
est-ce qu'il ne s'agirait pas par hasard
l'artichaut
oui tu as trouvé avait à trouver
l'artiste chaude mais pauvre enfant
jésus navré nous n'en tirons gmail 1
vous avez vu comment il écrire t-shirt
avec un dé à la fin ch a eu 10 as manche
où les artichauts mongeau c'est un
chahut dit je suis désespérément pauvre
ans vous fait désespérer désespéré oui
aux artichauts ça s'écrit comme ça c'est
h à une et bien entendu à la fin un
terrain tout voilà comme on écarte
ishola laquelle mme excuse moi je ne
savais pas je ne savais pas je renonce à
lui que je sais c'est en tout cas ce qu
il veut encore le chiffre que tu veux
qu'elle reste de la touques encore été
toi match de la écoute moi moi ce que je
sais en tout cas c'est que souvent on
dit qu'on mange les feuilles d'artichaut
et bien ce n'est pas vrai un foehn et ne
se mange pas pas du tout quel sens elle
pousse sur les titres comme
comme toutes les plantes comme on les
mange pas et ça s'appelle tenez vous
bien ça s'appelle des bractées un des
bras d'un nom scientifique ça s'appelle
des bractées bizarre non mais tu n'es
pas bon tu ne connais pas l'orthographe
cinq ans qu'est-ce que je te trouve bien
nerveux il est très nerveux seul bémol
l'escargot en attendant nous avons fini
il va encore avoir sa crise
nous allons retrouver bell bell ça va
ouvrir des biches toi puisque tu es
pressé bell bell
commençons tout de suite mais c'est pas
tellement plus je suis prêt si c'est
plutôt que je suis de très bonne humeur
et bah tant mieux pour lui est de mes
meilleures la mahra envoyé des fleurs
aux a mis à huy la non tu me fais ça
remarque c'était facile pourquoi brasse
le ses passions il mauvais gag au
briquet denis aux petites boules jaunes
mozac de lilas et de mimosa le la voilà
je te signale tout de suite si tu as
envie de mon envoyé des fleurs les vies
de les prendre trop grande
car mon appartement est un peu petit je
n'ai pas la place des maîtres des
tournois mais quoi détournant à
détournent des tournesols et non si on
enlève ab nous dérange pas je crois ce
lien vous déranger dans un petit coin
des biens attendait belfort est bien
vrai que je suis avec fabrice plus ne
s'était pas même un petit air concentre
mon canard je disais donc pas de
tournesol et puis
rouge toi pour que ce soit des fleurs
fraîches et qui ne soit pas trop diplôme
n'est pas fan et oui voilà le sens tu
sais j'aime tellement les fleurs que je
voudrais avec eux crillon en des nez
partout en dessiner dessinée si si c'est
ça en dessiner sur les murs de ma salle
de bain au dessus de proue babeau du
preuve à bord d'une la fabo voilà le la
au dessus du lavabo sur les casseroles
et surtout les huit ans le sais si tu
domines mal avant que j'ai fini par me
dis pas du jeu c'est super tu les aimes
les frères c'est ma joie de vivre comme
un cuisine sert à tout free jet de vitra
déjeuner et je t'offrirai un repas comme
aucun grand chef n'est capable d'en
prépa rue voilà s'essaiera que maudit un
repas de gala
pas de gala de gabat de gala voilà le la
voix poum voie positive à poux et voilà
et voilà à fait d'accord voilà c'est
fini dit mme amélie tu veux chanter un
petit truc nouveau son bilan wittmer
match quand il chantait un truc nouveau
séparés seulement view fait c'est vrai
c'est vrai nom roger vignes qu'on chante
tous ensemble clic est allé
l'état a mis ses jardins
les amis les cas il faudrait que la vie
majeur s'est désisté et g shock ceux des
chances mais comme juni bobinoir eelv
aura fait attention
il n'y aura pas de sens unique les caps
a mis son bureau car il aime la vie
oui
m
a joué aujourd'hui mais de voir devenir
un ami de vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]